for the first time ever Riot has added a
new gun to valerent the outlaw is a
semi-automatic sniper rifle that
promises to change valerent Forever by
being completely insane no way it does
body shot 140 you are lying no I swear
to God for
what oh it does work it does but is the
outlaw actually overpowered are players
overreacting because it's the first new
addition to the buy menu or could this
gun destroy valerant yeah
GG
damn now this gun is broken though like
really is that op I'm telling you like
you you have to buy correctly now like
if if you're a team that doesn't care
about economy you're going to
[Music]
lose okay so before we get into the
outlaw I just want to remind you all
that we have merch head over to shop.
thescore.com to check it out all right
so thanks to a leak the valerant
community was pretty nervous about the
outlaw for months before it came out
everyone realized pretty quickly that
the gun was clearly designed to combat
valerent light Shield metagame basically
more and more players were opting to buy
light Shields instead of heavy ones to
save money on Armor and spend more on
guns by December we finally had
confirmation that the outlaw would deal
140 damage with a body shot more than
enough to kill anyone not wearing heavy
Shields but 140 damage is pretty high
for a gun that only costs 2400 fires two
bullets at a time kills half armored
enemies with a single shot body damage
around 140 we can't buy half it has an
outlaw I can see I can see people hero
buying it you could buy it and half
armor every round
right oh my God this kind of scary know
for comparison the operator does 150
damage with a body shot and costs 4700
now the operator is designed to one-hot
anyone regardless of armor but the fact
that the outlaw only does 10 less damage
for a little more than half the price is
a little staggering players immediately
began discussing how this new sniper
could potentially impact anti Eco rounds
and the half armor meta before Riot
officially announced the outlaw with the
launch of the new episode now this was
an exciting time for valerant The Outlaw
was the first gun ever added to the game
in nearly 4 years since its release it
was Riot's answer to the light Shield
meta but was the light Shield meta
really such a bad thing during a
Challengers match back in 2022 NRG
innovated and debuted the strategy
against ghost gaming and although they
did lose the match they were able to
secure more buy rounds thanks to it the
reasoning was that if you know your
opponents are going to buy rifles like
the Vandals which will one shot headshot
you regardless of armor then why not
just buy light armor and save the cash
and thus the light Shield medow was born
players started saving the extra 600
credits even if they had the extra cash
to full bu this helped build up their
team's economy fanatic then popularized
the strategy throughout 2023
implementing it along their way to two
International titles but this Strat
wasn't just exclusive to Pro play
eventually casual players started using
it and heavy Fields just didn't feel as
valuable as they initially did when the
game first came out Riot saw this and
thought it was a problem so they started
innovating ways to punish those who were
abusing the light Shield meta but they
wanted to take it a step further we
definitely noticed that people were not
opting into heavy armor and like we're
saving a lot of money and so I don't I
would not say that this is like a direct
uh result the weapon as a result of that
but it is a weapon that uh like was made
with that thought in mind to also do
that but that's part of the reason is um
it doesn't do like 125 exactly is cuz
it's not supposed to be just a light
armor Slayer it's supposed to be um
something that does pack a heavy punch
and can give you other considerations uh
with like utility but when players
finally got their hands on the outlaw it
was unlike anything they'd ever seen
before no way it does body shot 140 you
are lying no it does I swear to God it
does 140
what
oh wait wait no one kill
anyone wait one more
where
sh little Outlaw a doesn't matter that
it's an Eco everyone shut the hell up so
like here you would definitely want like
this guy with the outlaw to find whippy
and then Force to fight on him to one
shot him or do that head him you have
the scripts oh my God almost immediately
Pros started calling the outlaw Noob
friendly and broken suggesting that it
marked the end of Eco rounds and think
about it the outlaw costs less than the
Vandal it's incredibly affordable which
should make it an everpresent threat
that punishes any team who isn't full
saving on eco rounds its existence in
the game should force players to buy
heavy armor basically every time they
buy and even casual players and analysts
started voicing their concerns over how
the new sniper would impact anti- Eco
rounds and the General Health of the
game I think it's broken I think if
teams did it with a chamber that at
least at least that's where I'm at I
think if teams did a chamber set it up
fully into buy rounds I think it's
broken cuz we're not thinking as well
like even if you get down to like 38 39
armor whatever are you re buying full
armor just for the sake of this gun and
stuff like that there's loads of little
nuances in terms of Chip damage where it
comes into play I don't I I think it's
still a broken gun I think um yeah we
just haven't haven't seen it properly
used yet but how does the outlaw really
impact the game and if you're someone
who enjoys picking up a sniper rifle in
valerant when should you buy it well to
answer that that question we're going to
toss things over to Colton cuz I don't
know I don't play valerant and now the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about I'm going to be real with all of
you I don't know why I'm here like I
don't know valerant can we get a new
monitor in here a graphics card a
mouse fine I'll do my research as we've
already mentioned the outlaw is of
course a semi-automatic sniper rifle
with a single 3.5 time zoom at 2400
credits it sits in between the Marshall
and operator in terms of price but the
damage values are what everybody is
focused on with this gun so let's talk
about them the Ola deals 238 to the Head
140 to the body and 119 to the legs in
terms of damage it's just slightly
weaker than an operator which deals 255
150 and 120 respectively but unlike the
operator The Outlaw has a two bullet
magazine size with a unique reload
feature reloading one bullet takes 2.3
seconds but if you empty the mag then
you'll have to wait 3.8 seconds to fully
replace it both the first and second
shot actually have a unique sound so you
can familiarize yourself with those and
then punish that lengthy 3.8 second
reload
time the outlaw also notably has high
penetration allowing you to wall bang
enemies and Destroy abilities like
killjoy lockdown but arguably the most
surprising stats on the outlaw are its
fire and hipfire accuracy it shoots at a
whopping 2.75 rounds per second which is
pretty nuts for a sniper rifle to put
that in perspective the Marshalls is 1.5
and the Ops is 0.6 so if you whiff or
leg your opponent on the initial shot
then there's a good chance you can still
recover in time to get the kill as for
the hip fire it's surprisingly good from
mid to close range it's not on the same
level as the Marshall but still better
than most people expected so the outlaw
is pretty clearly a wrong gun so should
you just buy it every chance that you
get not exactly due to the nature of TAC
FPS you're more likely to see snipers
like the outlaw on the defensive side
its price and the fact that it's capable
of one-shotting enemies with light armor
makes it the perfect gun on anti- ecos
and bonus rounds so if you press Tab and
see your opponents can't afford to buy
full armor then it's probably worth it
for someone on your team to buy an outla
for the most part this gun is going to
help streamline the first few rounds of
each half in general it's going to make
winning pistol rounds feel even more
valuable it's uh more for defense so
that you don't lose the anti- Eco cuz
with like force SPS and stuff like that
they can easily like flip the game and I
feel like it just like the outla is in
the game to make the first five rounds
more stable instead of like uh they win
the anti Eco they won the pistol though
like it kind of goes back and forth but
I think that Allah is going to stabilize
the game to make it so you just lose the
anti or you just lose the Eco after that
it's still early days so we'll see how
this gun continues to change the meta
this year especially once Pro play gets
fully underway but regardless it is nice
to see something fresh added to the game
that isn't just agents or Maps even if
valerant isn't exactly my cup of tea and
especially if Nile is just going to keep
making me talk about it anyway and that
was the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about so does the outlaw Mark
the end of the light Shield meta so far
yes before the outlaw players got used
to purchasing light Shields upgraded
sidearms and investing in some utility
even when they probably should have
saved now you got to put a little more
thought into your spending habits
especially if you're going up against
someone who's running an outlaw the gun
itself isn't busted but what it does to
the economy and how Pros will purchase
things every round you have to be more
careful about buying extra youy a sh
definitely shape the game yeah because
for me like I bought a I love the deagle
so like last year during like all my
tournaments I would buy a deagle all the
time and I'd be like 3700 credits and
I'd be light armor Vandal but like I
cannot do that anymore you have to like
have full armor or you could just get
one shot and then lose the round like we
said before the outlaw represents a
constant everpresent threat to those who
cheap out on their full buy no cash for
heavy armor get outlawed this in turn
rewards a team that's on a roll if
you've pressured your opponent's economy
to the point where they can't buy full
Shields then the outlaw represents a
cheap way to pick up a few kills and
cement your lead it's not the end of Eco
rounds forever but it is certainly an
extremely punishing tool to hurt any
team who is on eco this will make pistol
rounds more important make light Shields
almost unusable in a lot of contexts and
generally make games a little less
swingy as it'll be harder to turn around
a bad economic situation quickly now
it'll be interesting to see how pros
make use of the outlaw but it's safe to
say that it's serving the purpose that
Riot wants it to while also adding a
little bit more more structure to the
game's economy it's a whole new world
out there and maybe next time I enter it
I won't get run down by some kid with a
stinger thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring the notification Bell
for Unique bite-size videos you won't
find anywhere else hit us up on our
Twitter Instagram Facebook and Tik
Tok